I think it started from young...
I watched a lot of cartoons from Japan.
You had your "Gatchaman", "Captain Future" and "Transformers".
Whenever I look at my toys in my cabinets, I will think about all my childhood memories;
like how I used to save up money and run to the shop and purchase it.
I would take it out the box and just play with it with my friends.
Hi! My name is Simon Sim, I'm 49 years old and I'm a professional photographer.
I've been collecting toys for about 20 years.
My recent collection would be Kaiju Sofubi.
They are mainly from Japan, but there are some from the US and UK as well.
I would go to Japan once a year and try to get Kaijus there.
I try to make it for their toy conventions if possible, if not I'll get them from the stores.
Japanese they are very creative in their own ways and I find their culture is something I appreciate...
The Japanese people can really think out of the box
and they create all these funny-looking figures that I can't see anywhere else.
My collection consists of many various makers and brands like...
Bearbricks, Transformers, 3A from Hong Kong,
KAWS, Chogokin.
One of my favourite animation movie is 'Akira'.
I have the motorcycle from the movie.
I also have modular LEGO,
As well as Kaijus from Japan!
I did collect a few Kaijus before this but this particular piece is what made me go hardcore.
The one that makes these toys is Hirota Saigansho.
and he makes his own toys. [Sofubi]
So these are all handmade from his factory
and you can only get it via lottery.
I'm quite lucky that I got this for my first lottery.
It's been my favourite ever since.
I would treasure this for the rest of my life.
This is one of the rare Kaiju.
This is number 1 out of 30 pieces.
'King Gorilla Ju' also from Hirota
I was surprised I actually got #1, as the maker selects who will receive the toy.
Toys made in Japan still have one of the best plastics.
I'm not sure why, I believe they have a special mix in their plastics.
The combination is richer, it doesn't get sticky over time, even in the Singapore climate.
This is from US, this is MVH a.k.a Mutant Vinyl Hardcore from Mandarake.
His real name is Rich and he makes wonderful Kaijus
His paint job is quite nice
and this is one of the rare US toy makers that I follow.
Recently, it's getting a lot harder to get into his lottery
because there are too many collectors are going for his stuff.
People from all around the world are collecting Kaiju Sofubi now.
There are collectors from Taiwan, Thailand, China, Hong Kong
I'm competing with all these people, These toys are limited to only about 30 pieces.
It's still affordable, it's about a few hundred dollars, it's still okay for me.
The maker will actually list the price of the Kaiju. So if you think you can afford it, you can participate in the lottery.
To win a lottery, I think you need to be a bit lucky.
I try to keep my toys in my custom built cabinet.
I'll clean it maybe twice a year.
I've been collecting over 20 years
and I don't dare calculate how much I have spent
because I find putting everything in prices will have a different direction for me.
I try not to do that, but to estimate maybe...$50,000 for the past 20 years. I think it's reasonable.
On Kaijus alone, I have about 200 pieces.
I think collectibles are meant to be on display.
It's very sad to see them inside the box and not being able to see all of it.
You need to show the uniqueness of the shape and the vibrance of colours.
I love to display them, I can have a look any time I want to.
And share with my friends and family.
When you come to my place to see my toys, you will discover bits and pieces. You will see something new everytime.
I don't stick to a particular collection because I like variety
and also following a different phase in my life - it's always changing.
It's a changing of my thoughts and perspective.
Now everything is accessible online and very convenient.
It's different now, I have the money, I just need to click on the button and buy it!
In a way it lost a bit of that nostalgia from last time.
It's sad, but I still have the memories. That's why I started collecting.